looks like you have a lot of little ones
yeah I guess that is my style my mom
says I look like a sketchbook I come
here
what's up GQ I'm Paul Klein from Lanie
and this is my tattoo tour first one was
this 9 so all three of us in the band
lived in an apartment number 9 it's a
one-bedroom apartment and this is the
exact line that hung on the door we
wrote so many songs and made our first
few EPS in that one-bedroom apartment
and I didn't know where to go to get a
tattoo like I typed in tattoos in Yelp
and I found this place called Black
Diamond and this guy named Justin J cos
the reviews were insane they're like
dude if you're gonna go get your first
tattoo go to Justin he's the best and so
I called up Black Diamond and I went in
the next weekend what'd you guys get the
name Laney so I knew that I wanted to
have a four letter word for a band name
just for aesthetic purposes and I just
thought about Los Angeles and New York
and how the major cities of the country
but completely opposite and they're
almost like the antithesis of each other
and but they're both amazing in their
own respects so like Laney that's how
they came up with a band name I got this
heart so for love songs for a while like
the heart changes shapes when you move
your arm I was like did I put it too
close to like the center of access and
movement I'm so particular and I'm so
picky and if something goes wrong then I
stress about it like a year and then I
wish I hadn't died but I think it's
perfect I had drawn a heart and he like
made it absolutely perfect
so we played seven arenas with John
Mayer he's my hero I grew up
borderline worshiping yelling we got the
call to come out and open for him on
tour I knew that I wanted something I
thought seven tallies would be really
cool for the seven Riina's we played
with them that was just like a surreal
moment and now like he'll like my [ __ ]
on Instagram and sometimes I can't
believe that like my hero knows that I
exist and like likes a photo or responds
to DM it's a really crazy life ya got LA
on my finger I've had it done a couple
times because the first time I got it
done we were writing our first album and
we're up in the house in Malibu and I
had this battery-powered keyboard that I
would sit out in like the garden and
play all the time and my hands got
roasted from the Sun and so it kind of
faded my tat I wasn't very responsible
with it when I got it so many once told
me they thought I was really magnetic
and I thought that was one of the nicest
things anyone ever said to me so I got a
magnet that's good on me
I just want to go throughout my day
really purposefully and like draw
goodness towards my way and sometimes
will pray that I'm like at the right
place at the right time and the right
conversation with the right people you
know my dad took me to Free Willy as a
kid a matinee cried my eyes out I think
mainly because that's the first Michael
Jackson song I ever heard will you be
there I'm just still my favorite Michael
Jackson song so I got the whale oh man
that's my favorite my favorite animal
killer whale got this with Halsey early
on being in Laney those shows with her
and choice of on were really pivotal for
our careers they have really locked in
intense fan bases and it was really fun
to get in front of those people every
night but then we went on our own tour
about a year later and she called me out
of the blue is like I just miss come
into a Laney show I was like well why
don't you come to Minneapolis so she
just hopped on a plane and flew to
Minneapolis and that was November 5th so
we were at the hotel room like after we
played with a bunch of friends and we
like should we get tattoos tonight and
I was like let's get something symbolic
of the date so it's 11 which is November
and we played the show on the fifth and
we got tattooed on the 6th I had a
couple beers so like I think I had said
to the guy like make sure that this is
legit but here's the say I was like
petting koi fish in the pond that night
so it was one of those nights so I got
buddy on my arm it was my uncle growing
up my mom would always speak very highly
of him and I caught my first fish with
uncle buddy he bought me my first watch
I didn't know my grandpa so he was kind
of like my standing and grand falling so
he like worked at the shipyard his whole
life so I kind of you know got something
similar to like a sailor Jerry fall but
I've always liked just simple black
tattoos I don't think I'll ever get
color it's just not for me
this one I I got thanks on the back of
my arm I spent a long time cuz that's my
handwriting and I wanted to put it in
cursive um the H is just a little too
pointed this is how picky I am you know
and also my arm was bent when he
tattooed and it should have been down
but you live and you learn right and all
three of us in the band we all just got
kind of gratitude intense Jake just got
thanks the word thanks and the Lescott
thank you I got this big flower on my
arm thanks probably one of the best ones
I have it's just really simple but
flowers have always like worked their
way into like our band aesthetic and I
won't say what street I live on but it's
Spanish for flowers
got your loss tattooed on my shoulder
it's just a statement that I always want
to be true like anytime anybody kind of
turns me down or says no that it's their
loss not mine which places the
responsibility on me to be like the best
version of myself at all times and just
got like a little chest banger it's a
little and right here on my collarbone
it says X my age that's fur cross my
heart anything on your back or legs not
yet but I wanted to get maybe like a
moon right in the middle of my neck and
maybe tram Stan
Brad Pitt has like a [ __ ] stamp wait he
did the GQ video and you see it for just
a split second like when his shirts
flapping in the wind and I was like I
had no idea Brad Pitt had a [ __ ] stamp
I think like I might need a [ __ ] stamp
so that could be my next one actually
like a simple line wave just like across
my back I'll come back and show you the
trans